ag non il est persuadé de gagner mais il
est extrêmement marqué il faut le dire
extrêmement secoué par tout ça dans le
point PIP on va aussi parler d'un due
NEX de Benjamin casteldi he ah oui Flav
Flam ou bah oui récemment sur les
réseaux sociaux elle a été fortement
critiqué sur son physique elle a donc
décidé de répondre à ses haters d'une
manière très originale en publiant une
photo de ses fesses regardez voilà voilà
donc
voilà et et elle a mis un elle a mis un
mot bien entendu ceci est une lune un
popotin un pétard les fesses d'une femme
qui cette anné F c'est 50 ans alors que
mon entretien dans 50 minutes est
annoncé pour demain sur insta je lis
dans un commentaire que je suis
méconnaissable depuis ma prise de poids
ça tombe bien je ne cherche pas à être
reconnu j'aspire juste à être connu pour
ce que je suis depuis toujours pour ce
que je deviens aussi et et c'est vrai
que ceci est ma lune voilà donc elle a
dit vous m'avez connu percher sur des
talons un pied dans l'anorexie torturant
mon corps pour pour être couture à la
une des magazines sur sur les plateaux
de télé pour plaire et recueillir ce qui
me paraissait un semblant d'affection
alors aujourd'hui je vous montre mes
fesses rebondit rebondit de de bonne
bouffe de plaisir enfin recouvré de vin
et de caresses de fesses des fesses de
joie des fesses de vie pour inviter des
ignorants à se taire mais surtout
surtout pour vous dire de vous aimer mon
héro
[Applaudissements]
elle évoque aussi le viol à l'âge de 13
ans et franchement le texte est très
bien écrit c'est r se rend pas compte de
la violence par exemple quand je citerai
pas des noms mais des chanteuses qui
sont un peu plus enrobé que la normale
se sur les réseaux sociaux mais c'est
c'est de la grossophobie tout le monde
s'en fout personne n'en parle personne
ne défend ça mais c'est d'une violence
incroyable non mais c'est vrai alors en
plus dans l'interview de 50 Minutes
Inside qui a tout déclenché elle disait
justement qu'elle n'avait jamais été
aussi bien dans son corps qu'elle était
bien dans sa tête et que si elle
aimerait bien récupérer ses jambes de 25
ans ou sa poitrine de 30 bah ça
l'empêchait pas d'être très bien avec
elle-même quoi oui qui se passe il y a
des rondeur et puis a aussi le fait
qu'elle a en fait les gens ont grandi et
vieilli avec elle c'estàd qu'on l'a
connu très très jeune à la télévision et
donc effectivement y a pour les femmes
effectivement beaucoup plus que pour les
hommes parce que les hommes on dit
jamais tu as grossi ou tu as vieilli
mais pour les femmes il y a une
injonction à il faut rester mince et il
faut pas vieillir effectivement il y a
on est tout le temps très très très jugé
sur le physique vous avez des trucs vous
qui vous blessent vous sur les réseaux
ou pas des trucs qu'on vous a dit dites
la
vérité quo vous bah ouais vieill jum jum
ouais souvent j'ai vieil jum vie un Jok
qui mais vous traité de vieill jum ah
oui mais très souvent ça ça VI ou ça
c'est best ouais best c'est genre le
Poulin ça
J ou toi toi moi pas sur pas tellement
sur les réseaux mais dans pas sur les r
non mais dans la vraie vie je suis
victime de grossophobie tout le temps ah
bah bien sûr c'est mais Ben dans la
vraie viille alors c'est vrai que je
suis assez râuse donc par exemple un
jour un monsieur nous double dans une
file d'attente à la boulangerie va pas
dire dans
une j'ai F d'attente je suis rattrapé on
dire dans uneatt et donc je et ben je
lui dis non mais ça va vous gênez pas
vous doublez tu ferais bien de aller
dans une boulangerie enfin c'est que ça
c'est que ça ah non mais les réflexions
sur sur mon poids dès que je Râ à bonéan
parce que je r toujour l'histoire
l'anecdote était pourrie tu mais non
mais c'est c'est c'est tu as dit ça le
con mais ouais bien sûr et alors dans
l'indifférence générale c'est-à-dire que
je me prends sal grosse enfin tout ça
dans l'indifférence générale non mais
salale grosse je me le prends tout le
temps mais bien sûr dans la rue mais et
et moi ça va je m'en sors j'ai une mais
mais les gens qui sont hyper complexés
qui sont pas connus et qui se prennent
ça tout le temps mais c'est c'est ça la
vie de quelqu'un qui a du surpoids je
suis désolé on en parle jamais c'est moi
c'est l'insulte qui qui m'arrive dans la
tronche à chaque fois que je Râ sur un
truc moi c'est le racisme sur ma
compagne Fatou voilà bah oui là c'est
donc c'est pas sur son physique voyez
alors que les femmes ici ex ça vra Phi
rien qu'estce que vous voulez
dire c'est vrai non mais c'est fou vous
vous ben pareil moi les gens un peu
vieill avec moi aussi donc c'est plus
que c'était tu vois si on remet une
image époque TF1 ah c'est plus que
c'était bah oui j'ai j'ai 30 ans de plus
ou 20 ans de plus ou 15 plus on me dit
que je suis gros moi
aussi espè de gros vaaire ta d cassé ta
viille vra gr C maintenant tu as de
l'argent avec la télé pourquoi tu fais
pas refaire tes chic ou pas envie c'est
les gars
qui alors je répond c'est mon histoire
je laerai pas là m'a dit merde retour de
manger des glaces et c'est quelqu'un
bien informé parce que j'adore les
crèmes
glacées sac à
merdeour mais vousz c'est mic vous
recevez vous que des compliments sur
votre physique comment le critiquer en
même temps je vous dire moi je regarde
rien c'est lui qui mange le plus total
mais moi je reproche est-ce qu'on vous
reproche d'être trop beau parfis et je
vais vous dire moi ils peuvent
m'insulter tout ce qu'ils veulent ça
vous Mo tap total le soir je suis dans
mon
jacuzzi que je pense à tous ces cons qui
m'inuse je peux vous dire franchement je
me dis tu vois je suis peut-être je suis
mieux queeux tu vois vous bah moi
franchement on dit plein de choses mais
je m'en fous ça rentre même pas dans une
oreille ou dans aut orifice je m'en fous
ça rou
rou c'est
incroyable parle que de ça mais c'est
uneée c'est uneée non mais sans déconner
dans un autre
Orou pensez à ça en fait tout je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé pendant les
vacances po un problème il a un problème
psychologique non mais sans décon qui s
passé là en polne mais je pense qu'elle
trop de Vass cornichon en vrai on rigole
mais c'est c'est normal que ça nous
touche quand même si c'est pour enfin
voilà je trouve que se prendre une
insulte de manière frontale que ce soit
sur les réseaux ou dans la rue moi l'ARE
jour il y a un mec et pareil je suis
passé devant un kebab un mec qui
m'arrêtaé il me dit le gros ça va mais
je pour rigoler non mais c'est
vrai arrête de
rigoler vous jure sur ma tête je vous
jure sur ma tête alors déjà je me suis
retourné quand il a dit le gros mais
c'est c'est en vrai on peut en rigoler
et cetera mais c'est quand même très
frontal et on va pas on va pas pleurer
parce qu'on est la télé mais c'est des
choses qu'on dirait pas aux gens dans la
vraie vie les gens sou se permettent de
dire des choses peut-être parce qu'il
imaginent ça nous attend pasou parce
qu'on lit pas les choses et c'est vrai
que ça fait de la peine JAC toi moi ce
que je trouve c'est qu' a une très
grosse différence entre ce que les gens
peuvent dire dans la rue où moi les gens
sont très gentils avec moi et sur les
réseaux où
c'est
facho un peu comme toi tu es tombé bien
bas par rapport à ce que tu as pu faire
voilà des choses comme ça qui sont qui
sont blessantes mais rien sur le
physique rien sur le physique non rien
sur le physique
[Rires]
bizarre
bizarre toi non moi les gens me
félicitent plutôt
je c'est magnifique j'adore ce gars
j'adore non mais char non franchement
non honnêtement vraiment vraiment quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il y a vous non moi aussi
très souvent on on m beaucoup vous êtes
sûr parce
que on m beaucoup traité de de [__] quoi
on va beaucoup plus juste parce que gen
je sais pas moi je mets des ons comme ça
je vous arrêtez
jamais non mais c'est vra on beaucoup
traité de ça alors que par exemple
pendant très longtemps au début quand
j'étais sur les Réau j'étais vierge et
tout le monde disait oh la plus grosse
[__] Mach machin alors que pas du tout
les gens just ce soir curieuse méthode
non mais c'est vrai non c'est vrai la
bille ne fait pas le moine et le
trottoir ne fait pas la [__] allez
sortez on se retrouve dans un instant on
va continuer à parler tout ça et on
offera un po de long et puis on aura
vous allez voir un témoignage de fou à
tout de suite à tout de
suite hey hey he he he